pour parler de cette pandémie nous
sommes en direct avec michel onfray
philosophe
bonsoir michel onfray merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france encore
peut-être plusieurs semaines de
confirmant de confinement s'est pas
vraiment une surprise qu'elle et vous
votre réaction
mais non c'est pas une surprise on voit
bien que le président de république
navigue à vue qu'il cody hay et qu'il
faille vient séduit en même temps c'est
en même temps à droite à gauche on va à
droite on va à gauche on ne sait pas
trop ce qu'on fait il y avait une
politique possible une autre politique
possible qui n'était pas celle qu'il a
choisie celle que les caennais sont
plurielles qui aurait été effectivement
de confiner très vite et très tôt en
faisant de manière individuelle et
personnelle en prison telle sorte que
des tests soient effectués sur les gens
individuellement personnellement
massivement pour faire de telle sorte
que effectivement on confine mais pas la
polluer la population entière la
totalité de la france
regardez comment ça fonctionne et à
taïwan regarder comment ça fonctionne et
en allemagne et les allemandes sont à
moins de 100 morts ces deux noms
beaucoup trop mais c'est quand même tout
à fait autre chose que ce qui nous
arrive à nous donc effectivement il y
avait une autre politique possible mais
on ne sache pas que haendel bach on
dispose d'un autre logiciel que le
logiciel de maastricht qui suppose que
effectivement le marché doit faire la
loi et on s'aperçoit que dans une
configuration comme celle ci le virus
s'étend et planétaire le marché parce
que l'on ferait est-ce que c'est
forcément la faute d' emmanuel macron
parce que clairement le souci semble
qu'on avait pas ces tests ou comme on
n'avait pas les masques disponibles on
n'avait tout simplement pas les moyens
de cette politique tout simplement est
ce que c'est une politique il n'aurait
pas fallu anticipaient bien bien en
amont
ja je ne vous fais pas bien mais il
savait que macro noté chez hollande que
hollande s'entend bien avec sarko que
sarko était copain comme cochon avec
chirac et que chirac s'entendait bien
finalement avec mitterrand enfin que
globalement depuis que le général de
gaulle est parti en 1969 il ya une seule
et même politique en france c'est celle
du libéralisme du marché diffus lagoy et
peu importe que finalement change de
paquets cadeaux vaguement la droite
vaguement la gauche ne finalement des
libéraux dit maastricht et c'est la
politique globale de tous ces gens là
leur bien sûr macron n'est pas
responsable de tout ça mais il est
responsable de s'inscrire dans un
grillage qui est celui ci et qui fait
effectivement qu'il n'y a pas de masque
et voilà pourquoi il dit que le masque
ne sert à rien il n'a pas non plus de
tests et voilà pourquoi il dit les tests
ne servent à rien plutôt que de dire
nous n'avons pas de masque parce que
c'est l'impéritie de la france qui
n'existe plus depuis qu'elle est dans
l'europe nous n'avons pas de test parce
que c'est l'impéritie de la france
depuis que la france n'existe plus et
qu'elle est diluée dans l'europe
fédérale qui elle-même vise une espèce
de grand état universel planétaire où le
capital serait la loi mais de fait
puisqu'on ne fait plus de géopolitique
puisqu'on fait plus de géostratégie
puisqu'on ne fait plus de politique à
proprement parler et bien effectivement
on découvre que le roi est nu et quand
il s'agit d'une pandémie est bien le
libéralisme ne saurait faire la loi
parce qu'effectivement on retrouve les
vielles les vieilles choses le
souverainisme les frontières qu'il faut
faire mais l'état souverain la décision
du chef de l'état le pouvoir et la
puissance de la police et de l'armée
ça y est formidable ça fait 20 ans que
l'idée que ces choses-là sont
l'essentiel est nécessaire et l'état
dans lequel nous nous trouvons c'est que
nous retrouvons les idéaux de tout
souverainiste qui se respecte le premier
tour des municipales qui a été maintenue
effectivement un confinement qui est
arrivé assez tard parce que ça on avait
les moyens en tout cas de décider avant
vous nous l'expliquer comment justement
pour des raisons purement économiques ou
peut-être le fait de sous-estimer un
danger ont simplement il explique pour
les par l'extrême jeunesse d'emmanuel
macron par son innocence au sens
étymologique par le fait qu'il n'est pas
un homme politique par le fait qu'il est
un individu placé par l'état profond les
journalistes les économistes et
fiscalistes la finance enfin tous ces
gens l'instn espèce d'homme de paille
il ne connaît pas d'autres logiciels que
le libéral et il ne sait pas quoi
choisir finalement la politique c'est
quoi je vous renvoie à karachi quelques
autres c'est l'art de la décision ou au
général de gaulle le fil de l'épée c'est
le chef qui décide qu'il faut faire ceci
pas faire cela qu'il faut aller dans
cette direction mais pas dans celle ci
et lui ne sait pas c'est l'homme du en
même temps il faut bien la droite veut
bien la gauche s'il veut bien dire que
il faut se confiner mais en même temps
une fois aller voter qu' il ne faut pas
sortir avec en même temps qu'un match de
foot quand il s'agit de l'italie et de
la france que c'est interdit de sortir
mais qu'en même temps pour faire du
sport c'est le contraire d'un chef
emmanuel macron donc de fait c'est un
jeune homme qui est arrivé au pouvoir
alors qu'ils n'avaient pas 40 ans qui
avait avec lui l'assemblée nationale le
sénat et la totalité des journaux
presque deux ou trois titres et encore
et qui a gâché tout ça parce que
finalement on découvre d'un seul coup
que ce jeune homme ne sait pas faire de
la politique il est juste l'homme de
paille du capital capitaliste du
libéralisme de l'argent du veau d'or et
d'un seul coup le corps d'un virus fait
la démonstration effectivement que la
mécanique et celle ci nous a fait des
années que je dénonce cette mécanique et
d'un seul coup le dos ou comme au
théâtre et on découvre que le roi est nu
aujourd'hui il y en eut du sort la chine
vient en aide à l'europe la russie
notamment cuba même vient en aide à
l'italie
qu'est ce que ça dit selon vous sa vie
que tous ces gens qui nous allons
présenter comme des libéraux comme des
dictateurs comme des résurgences
d'adolphe hitler et son de la politique
je ne dis pas que je souscris à cette
politique
je ne souscris à la politique d'erdogan
que je souscris à la politique de trump
que de souscrire la politique de poutine
je dis simplement que ces gens là font
de la politique et que nous ne faisons
plus de la politique comme nous estimons
que le capitalisme doit faire la voir ce
que vise macron ce que vise l'europe
matricielle l'europe libérale europe
soutenus par la cia et jean monnet
depuis la sortie de la guerre de la
deuxième guerre mondiale 6 1 et à
universel pour utiliser le vocabulaire
de young et c'était pas universelle
c'est finalement le gouvernement
planétaire de gentilles helsinki
finalement il faut faire l'économie des
peuples et que l'économie des peuples
nous permet le gouvernement de manière
saint simonienne des techniciens les
traitant du technicien des prétendus
technocrates et des gens qui savent et
d'un seul coup on découvre tout ça on
découvre que cette machine qui
fonctionne et qui fait de la politique
c'est la politique du capital du
capitalisme finalement
elle est totalement incapable de gérer
ce genre de choses et que seuls sont
capables de gérer ces choses les gens
qui sont capables de faire de la
politique pas défendre le gouvernement
chinois je dis simplement que en chine
est effectivement on a su gérer le
problème alors je vous dis pas il faut
que con con qu'on passe à une dictature
c'est pas mon propos je dis juste que
quand les hommes politiques font de la
politique
quand ils sont capables de décider de
cette belle phrase de nietzsche un oui
ou un non ligne droite et bien
effectivement on est capable de
souscrire aux chefs et de dire oui le
chef de l'état c'est quelqu'un avec qui
on a envie de dire oui
si la ligne claire le chef de l'état
aujourd'hui n'a pas de ligne chez
emmanuel mâcon clairement sans entend en
un fléchissement de sa politique
commençait d'ailleurs avec ses voisins
européens la règle des déficits qu'ils
veulent on etc loi quelle que soit ce
que ça coûte
pour vous il y aura vraiment un avant et
un après on apprend c'est le sont
peut-être rien mais je ne crois pas moi
je vais vous de fillon quand il était
premier ministre de sarkozy qui nous
disait que l'état était en faillite et
qu'on ne pouvait pas effectivement
augmenté de quelques centimes le smic
des gens les plus modestes et les plus
pauvres et qui quelque temps plus tard
trouvait tout de même de l'argent pour
bombarder kadhafi qui était un chef
d'état un laïc c'est à dire qu'il
contenait l'islamisme intégriste on
connaît l'histoire pas d'argent pour les
pauvres mais de l'argent pour bombarder
les régimes islamistes laïques et à ce
moment là on découvre effectivement que
quand on veut trouver de l'argent que
l'on trouve donc on voit bien
actuellement que d'un seul coup toute
l'économie ses ventes mais qui
globalement tout trouver de l'argent
pour les les entreprises pour les
artisans pour les gens qui ne peuvent
pas aller travailler aux y tient dans
cette cour
toute cette politique souverainiste
cette fois-ci peut-être c'est un vrai
question clé publique
we made you more c'est à dire que vous
avez l'impression que quand il y avait
un paysan qu'il se pendait tous les
jours ce n'est pas une question de vie
ou de mort que quand les gens se jettent
dans l'alcoolisme dans la drogue ou dans
la dépression nerveuse s'était pas non
plus une question de vie ou de mort
parce qu'ils étaient chômeurs parce
qu'ils étaient précaires etc pensé que
c'était un problème devenu morts sont
des ce sont des morts qu'on ne voit pas
alors évidemment il est votre problème
mais le capitalisme fabrique des morts
au quotidien l'avenant seul coup on voit
des cercueils alors on se dit ah
effectivement les visibilités les gens
ont besoin d'image pour penser
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est assez
problématique
il ne ne savent pas penser si on leur
montre pas une montagne de cercueils si
vous montrez une montagne de cercueil
d'un seul coup ils disent là bon sens et
quelque chose à penser dans cette
aventure
si tous les soirs nous montrions visage
du personnage du paysan qui s'est
suicidé dans la journée nous
comprendrions effectivement qu'il ya vu
une épidémie à cause du libéralisme et
que finalement le libéralisme tuer des
gens mais ça effectivement le le capital
n'a pas envie de montrer les médias qui
font partie du capitalisme globalement
ou qui reflète l'idéologie capitaliste
n'ont pas intérêt non plus aller à le
montrer mais je crois simplement qu au
sens photographique du terme je pense à
l'époque de la photographie argentique
mais il y avait des révélateur au sens
photographique du terme et d'un seul
coup
ce virus est une espèce de révélateur
qui montre ce qu'est la véritable
photographie de notre époque
nous sommes dans une dictature il
libéral pour utiliser le vocabulaire de
ces gens là quand nous sommes dans la
logique de schengen l'europe maastricht
yonne en relève d'une logique libérale
le libéralisme dont on nous a dit qu'il
règlerait la totalité des problèmes de
règle aucun problème
cette espèce de monstre dont on nous a
dit qu économiquement il serait capable
de faire pièce aussi bien à la russie
aux états unis ou à la chine n'est pas
capable de produire des masques nemanja
de produits il tombe à cause de
l'incapacité à produire des masques dont
les médecins qu'il envoie à la mort
merci beaucoup michel onfray d'avoir été
avec nous en direct ce soir sur rtl
france